I feel incredibly loyal and
responsible to the original show
I have a great kind of
desire to even be in the same
room as that show because it was a game changer
george and his writing was a huge influence on me
it's an incredible feeling to achieve my dream job
you get that great call which is the
thing that every writer is hoping for
telling you we're going to go make this
thing and you're happy for a few seconds
and then you realize the
responsibility that's on your shoulders
i'm excited it's always a little apprehensive when
you turn your baby over to foster parents but i'm
involved in this it's great to have ryan who's a
great writer and someone who really knew my world
he's going to do his best to remain faithful
to it i knew miguel supatrick was an amazing
director he'd won an emmy he'd done some of our
best episodes there's always a little suspense to
how good is it going to be but i think
i'm in good hands with ryan and miguel
the idea of going back to westeros
was almost too much of a challenge
you have to start by respecting it you can't
start by doing different for different sake
he saw some of the things that i saw and it wasn't
just a prequel for prequel's sake there
was actually a reason to tell the story
it really was seeing it through a different
perspective that interested me men would
sooner put the realm to the torch and
see a woman ascend the iron throne
george's work really is a truly immersive world
there's unexplored deep recesses
and thousands of years of history
realizing what worked in thrones what didn't what
do we want to better how do we want to evolve
the biggest sets i've ever been
on the biggest locations i've
ever been on the biggest cruise
i've ever seen it's staggering
we do really see the creative world very similarly
we're gonna start just a more grounded more
intimate way we're gonna go off and go on
this great adventure together what a great
new chapter in the game of thrones saga
Welcome back everyone happy comic con week this
is going to be my new house of the dragon game of
thrones video they dropped a bunch of new footage
so we'll break it down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes i will be doing videos for all the
episodes and we are going to be getting even more
trailer footage this week so there'll be another
video later this week as well i'm also going to
be going to the premiere of house of the dragon
but they're just going to be showing episode one
i don't know when i'm going to be allowed to post
my non-spoilery review but as soon as they let us
of course i'll post a non-spoilery review but the
new trailer video obviously starts with the new
showrunners completely different showrunners than
dan and dave dan and dave aren't involved with the
new show the new showrunners in george r martin
hyping up the show and explaining how they treated
it versus the main game of thrones show now there
are a lot of familiar things a lot of familiar
places designs but that are depicted in very
different ways because of the way they treated
things at this earlier point in the timeline
like most of the scenes feature dragonstone in the
red keep but they show them in very different ways
they look very different like their dragon designs
all over everything because what happened is later
in the timeline after robert's rebellion
when robert baratheon took the iron throne
he basically had all the targaryen stuff wiped
from the red keep as much as possible the series
is meant to take place about 200 years before the
events of the main show before robert's rebellion
that's why it looks so much more ornate during
all these new trailer scenes i'll point out some
of the cool easter eggs as we go along because
there are some really funny and some really cool
easter eggs they worked in behind the scenes the
other big thing here too is george r martin being
involved with the series so actually what happened
is is he hired ryan condol first to adapt fire and
blood into the show itself then it became a
show at hbo so even though they're like seven
plus game of thrones spin-offs prequels sequel
shows that they're developing right now including
the jon snow sequel series house of the dragons
started life specifically as george r martin's
show that he was developing and that he brought
other people on before he went to hbo and said
hey make this show after that they basically wound
up poaching all the best talent from the original
game of thrones main show and bringing them to
house of the dragon so that's how they get miguel
sapochnick who most of you will probably remember
is the director of battle of bastards hard home
pretty much like all the biggest best episodes of
game of thrones that's why when he starts talking
they show footage from battle of the bastards and
from heart home a lot of these trailers meant to
show you the architecture specifically on the
show and how detailed they got with it all these
up-close designs of all the dragons like all these
dragon moldings all over everything like i said
mostly meant to be inside the red keep and in and
around the dragonstone castle there's a little bit
of footage on driftmark i'll point that out when
we get to that part of the trailer there's also
footage of a bunch of different battle scenes
and it seems like it's from the same battle in
a couple tournament scenes that i'll point out as
we get to that part too it wouldn't be a game of
thrones show if there weren't any giant battles
one of the jokes about game of thrones that a lot
of people tell is that especially in the earlier
seasons some of the best episodes were just about
them having really really good meetings so i
think they brought a lot of that back during
house of the dragon like yes they will do big
spectacular battles but a lot of it will feel
like the dramatic stuff that you remember
from the earlier seasons of game of thrones
they show you a lot of footage from the inside of
this particular room inside the red keep notice
all the dragon lights all along the walls of the
staircase here this is the same room with the open
ceiling that we saw cersei in during season
seven with a big map of westeros drawn on the
floor obviously like i said when robert baratheon
won robert's rebellion he basically had all signs
of targaryen everything like all their designs
all their sigils all their artifacts just kind
of wiped from the red keep as much as possible
that's why he moved all the dragon skulls down
to a lower floor so that he didn't have to look
at them cersei also kind of sarcastically joked
that he would bring some of his women down here
from time to time too probably one of the other
biggest parts of the trailer though is this crazy
room inside dragonstone with the skull of blurring
the black dread i think that it's in dragonstone
it could be somewhere inside the red keep though
but just based on the look of the architecture in
the walls it seems like it's inside dragonstone
so just to be clear at this point in the timeline
when the show picks up blurring the black thread
has already died this is meant to be his skull and
this room around him just seems like a ceremonial
burial chamber meant to honor him a lot of
people wondered what's going on here with
it being surrounded by the skulls of a bunch of
other dead targaryen soldiers it seems like it all
seems like they have similar headwear and their
appearance just makes it seem like it's meant to
be ceremonial like they're meant to either protect
or serve valerian in death also if you look in the
background too the mural all around the walls of
this particular room seem like the story of the
targaryen family just drawn onto the walls a lot
of the other footage is meant to show you in and
around the iron throne room and in and around the
brand new but old iron throne now made from many
many more swords than you saw during the original
show the funny way they're explaining this is that
it's meant to be more book accurate it was made
of thousands of swords that were melted down by
valerian the black dread by aegon the conqueror
this is what it actually looks like in the books
but because that's incredibly impractical to
film in a room like this the virgin on house
of the dragon is meant to look like the compromise
but because there's still hundreds of swords that
they had to use as props to create this they
actually worked in a bunch of easter eggs so
like there are swords from the witcher there's
some warcraft swords that they worked in here
and those are just meant to be fun easter eggs
like obviously kind of breaks the universe if
you think about crossing over with the witcher and
warcraft other big fantasy universes it's just the
production designers and the showrunners having
a little bit of fun behind the scenes so let me
know if you think you can spot the warcraft swords
and the witcher swords in here in the iron throne
this is a new scene of grammy tavis and the
kingsguard graham mctavish is playing harold
westerling he was lord commander of the kingsguard
under viserys the first targaryen when he died
before the actual dance of the dragons before the
civil war kristen cole became the lord commander
that's who this is you also see scenes of him
fighting damon targaryen where he's wearing his
giant dragon armor and wielding the dark sister
valerian blade there's a couple scenes with damon
targaryen wielding dark sister like this is meant
to be a completely different battle scene during
a different part of the timeline all the dragon
armor here is actually meant to be similar to the
dragon armor that rhaegar eventually wore later
in the timeline but the thing with dark sister is
that that valyrian blade actually wound up being
wielded by the blood raven who then took the black
and then went north of the wall to become
the three-eyed raven and supposedly he just
took the sword with him when he went to become the
three-eyed ravens so theoretically during the main
show when the night king and the white walkers
attacked the weirwood while bran was being trained
dark's sister was inside the tree with them
while that was happening there are a couple other
valerian blades that we see during the trailer
there's a dagger that damon targaryen is holding
but it's not the same cat's paws dagger like it's
a completely different hilt completely different
blade even though there were a lot more valyrian
weapons during this period in history they were
still incredibly rare and incredibly valuable so
it wasn't just like everybody and their sister had
a valyrian blade the funny thing about the cast
paws dagger too that you see an older version of
alison wielding attacking older rainer with like
she's trying to stab her with this valyrian dagger
the showrunner actually said that it's not meant
to be the actual cat's paws dagger even though
it looks almost exactly the same they said it is
the same prop like it is the actual same physical
dagger but they redesigned it and they wanted it
to be a different dagger on the show which seems
kind of weird but the other big notable valyrian
blade is actually wielded by viserys the first
targaryen in his blackfyre the sword that belonged
to aegon the conqueror the reason that sword was a
big deal is because it was passed down from each
new targaryen king after aegon the conqueror and
it was meant to be sort of like a right to
rule eventually it got lost during the later
blackfyre rebellions after most of them lost and
then went to the east to form the golden company
there's also a lot of scenes at the map table room
inside dragonstone like this dragon on the wall
here is from inside the map table room they've
obviously upgraded everything they've upgraded
the map table itself like you can see little
candles in the grooves here just to light it up
most of the scenes that we see inside the
map table room are from the older version of
vernier later in the timeline it seems like she
holds a lot of her war councils there as they
get ready for the actual dance of the dragons
there's a bunch of other really cool details in
this trailer here but probably the other biggest
thing is all the extra footage from what seems
like the first episode in the great council of
101 inside harrenhal that's where king jaharis
presided that's what's happening here like
they're walking out to king jahirus as he
presides over all the lords in the realm who were
voting for viserys the first his younger grandson
to be the next king originally viserys the first
was lower in the line of succession than princess
rhaenys this person here but the lords of the
realm did not want her as their next ruler so
they voted almost unanimously against her at the
great council it was like 20-1 vote against her
there's so much going on during these moments
in history we'll see how much time they spend
on it during the episodes but if i need to i
will do bonus videos about things specifically
in episodes because everything that happens during
all these different periods is a really big deal
but like i said it is comic con week there are
trailers coming for so many different things i'll
try to do videos for as much stuff as possible
there's a bunch of marvel trailers that will
be dropping a lot of the big movie panels will be
happening on saturday the new house of the dragon
trailer is supposed to come on friday so i'll
post a new video for that when it gets released
if there's any easter eggs or any questions that
you have about the series just write them below
in the comments and i'll try to add them to
my trailer video that i do on friday for this
i've done a couple new house of the dragon
videos recently i'll put the links for them
down in the description below everyone click
here for my brand new black panther 2 doctor
doom video and click here to learn about
the game of thrones jon snow sequel series
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!